Welcome back.
We're now going to start section
eight in test four.
Let's start with problem
number one.
Problem number one-- if 3 times
n minus 4 is equal to
18, what is n?
n is equal to what?
Let's divide both sides by 3.
You get n minus 4
is equal to 6.
Add 4 to both sides and
you get n equals 10.
And that is choice D.
Problem number two.
Right?
It was divided by-- well
you know what I did.
Hopefully you know what I did.
Two, for a class ring, each
senior can choose from 4 types
of stones and 3 types
of metal.
How many combinations of a stone
and metal are there?
Well, for each stone
they can pick 3
different metals, right?
So there's 4-- because there's
4 different types of stones--
and each of them can have
3 different metals.
So it's 4 times 3 combinations
which is choice D.
Next problem.
Problem three.
If you ever doubt yourself on
the first one or two problems
because it seems too easy, you
probably shouldn't doubt
yourself, because the first
couple of problems tend to be
reasonably straightforward.
I was just doubting myself
because I was like, was I
missing something?
All right.
Problem number three.
The sum of 3a and the square
root of b is equal to the
square of the sum of a and b.
Which of the following
is an expression for
the statement above?
Well, I just wrote it out.
It's choice B.
But hopefully, as I talked it
out, you saw what I was doing.
I said the sum of 3a and the
square root of b-- this is the
sum of 3a and the square root of
b-- is equal to the sum of
a plus b squared.
Or they said, equal to the
square of the sum of a plus b.
Next problem.
Problem four.
Carrie has a cordless telephone
receiver that can
operate within a range
of 1,000 feet.
1,000 foot range from the
telephone's base.
Carrie takes the receiver
from the base and walks
800 feet due north.
So this is the base and-- I
don't know if Carrie is a boy
or girl's name-- but Carrie
walked 800 feet due north.
From that point she walks due
east and stops at the maximum
range of the receiver.
In which of the following
directions can Carrie walk and
still be within range
of the receiver?
So the range is essentially
that you can go 1,000 feet
from this point b.
Right?
And actually, let me draw
it as a circle.
So I can go, at most-- so let
me draw the circle here-- so
let's say that this is the
point b, that's the base.
Let's say Carrie's a guy.
Carrie can get at most 1,000
feet away from the receiver.
So the furthest distance that
Carrie can get from the
receiver is 1,000 feet.
So this radius right
here is 1,000 feet.
And in the problem, Carrie
walks 800 feet due north.
So maybe right there.
That's 800.
And then he walks due east to
the range of the receiver.
So then walks east, which is
this direction, to the range
of the receiver, which
is right there.
And what they want to know is,
in which of the following
directions can Carrie
walk and still be in
range of the receiver?
Well, we know Carrie can't walk
north because then he or
she will be out of range
of the receiver.
Can't walk east. It would
be out of the
range of the receiver.
But he or she can walk south or
can walk back west, right?
So they can walk south or west.
And those are choices 2
and 3, which is choice E.
Choice E is 2 and 3, which is
due south or due west. They
can walk this way, south,
or west, that way.
Next problem.
Whoops.
Problem five.
If x over 4 is equal to 2x over
a, and x does not equal
0, what is the value of a?
Well, we can divide both sides
by x because we know x doesn't
equal 0, because you
can't divide by 0.
So this and this would
cancel out, right?
We're dividing both
sides by x.
So you get 1/4 is equal
to 2 over a.
And you could eyeball this,
but if you want to do it
mathematically, you could say 1
times a is equal to 4 times
2, which is 8.
And you could have said, well
2 is 1/4 of what number?
Well it's 8.
So a is equal to 8.
Choice A.
Problem number six.
And we have a little
drawing here to do.
Let's see, problem number six.
So we have a parallel line like
that, actually I don't
know if they're parallel yet,
because they haven't told me.
But it kind of looks like that,
although I shouldn't assume.
We have a transversal, if
those are parallel.
Let me switch colors.
OK.
So they're saying that this
angle right here is r.
This is u, s, t.
And this is line l.
This is line m.
In the figure above,
l is parallel to m.
So l and m are parallel.
I was right.
And r is 50 degrees.
So r is equal to 50 degrees.
What is the value of
s plus t plus u?
Well, what are the angles that
are corresponding to r?
If r is 50, the corresponding
angle here is, so this is kind
of the same-- if you don't
remember this, you might want
to review the geometry module
where I do this-- the
corresponding angle here is u.
And so this angle
is also going to
be equal to 50 degrees.
Let me do a different color.
So that equals 50, and that's
because they kind of take the
same role where the transversal
intersects the
parallel lines.
And if this is 50, this is the
opposite angle, right?
So that angle is also
going to be 50.
And t and u are supplementary,
right?
So t plus u is going
to be 180.
Or you could say that
this is 130, right?
So what's 50 plus 50 plus 130?
It's 100 plus 130.
It's 230 degrees, which
is choice A.
Next problem.
Invert colors.
Problem number seven.
In the x-y coordinate plane,
line l is perpendicular to the
y-axis and passes through
the point 5, negative 3.
So let me-- those are my axes.
y. x.
And this line-- I'll draw it in
green-- it passes through
the point 5, negative 3.
So that's like here someplace.
And it's perpendicular
to the y-axis.
This is the y-axis, so
perpendicular to it.
So it forms a 90 degree angle.
And we know this is
a 90 degree angle.
And it passes through the point
5, and then minus 3.
So this is the point
right here.
This is 5 comma minus 3.
Which of the following is an
equation of the line l?
OK, well what is the
slope of this?
It's a flat line.
As much as you run-- as much
as you have a change in x--
there's no change in y, right?
So the slope is 0.
And what's the y-intercept?
The y-intercept is where you
intersect the y-axis.
Well, you're going to intersect
it at y equals
negative 3.
So b is minus 3.
And if you don't-- I'm saying
this from the form-- y equals
mx plus b is the slope
of a line.
m is 0, b is 3, so we know the
slope is y equals negative 3.
That's the equation.
y equals negative 3,
that's choice C.
And in general, if you just drew
this line, you're like,
well, no matter what x is,
y is equal to negative 3.
And you could say, well
that's the equation.
y is equal to negative 3.
I have a minute left.
I don't think that's enough
time to do a problem.
It might be, but I don't
want to rush things.
So I'll do the next problem
in the next video.
I'll see you soon.